good evening welcome welcome welcome for
some of you can you just raise your hand
is this your first event as part of this
weekend welcome welcome welcome part of
my responsibility for welcoming you and
my pleasure in welcome you you to this
part of the event is to let you
understand how this all evolved please
know that the people on the event
committee led so ably by eve hart rice
so abling by eve hart rice never felt
that this was the culmination of
acknowledging the first women this is
the launch of acknowledging first women
this evening this weekend started almost
four years ago at the lunch table of
marta marette she brought together for
whatever reason a number of women it was
a small group but included was eve rice
from the class of 73 connie roister from
the class of 72 i was there from the
class of 71 linda Lorimer was there as
being a pivotal person involved and
interested in what's happening with
women and what's happening across the
university and a number of other people
kind of came in and out with some of
those meetings but it started almost
four years ago as we were talking about
women at yale what's happening now what
happened in the past how do we
acknowledge our past how does that get
infused and transferred and documented
and encouraged among the women who are
here now how have we gone out into the
world how did we get here
and in that process as we talked about
women across Yale and realized upcoming
was the hundred and fiftieth anniversary
of women at the University because the
first ones came in 1869 and those of us
who came to the college came in 1969 we
wanted to do things that would really
put in perspective what did we face we
know that there were women who came
before us who had it harder than we did
what happened to those women who came
there was only one woman here at the law
school were only two people at the
graduate school were only maybe one
person at the medical school we know
they had a difficult time and so we are
not here to diminish anything that they
went through or however they handled
themselves or what the university was
like then but we know that even women
who came to the college maybe in 1967 or
even 1980 may have had a difficult time
it's not to diminish that but one of the
things we felt truly was that the women
who came when we did had a unique
experience it took having a critical
mass coming at the same time
specifically to the college that changed
the life of every woman at this
university it admit a push for more
faculty it meant a push for more
administrators it meant a push for all
kinds of things and in this conversation
we acknowledge that there were men in
our classes and who preceded us who
helped to make this happen we do not
diminish that at all and we knew that
there were men who came with us who
really are her staunch allies but the
key thing that we kept saying to
ourselves is many of us never knew each
other when we were here we were spread
out across the 12 residential colleges
and even the women who came and we're at
Vanderbilt were not necessarily
encouraged to meet together and it's not
as though we wanted to be isolated from
buddy in this room who was really one of
our staunch allies but we felt that this
was our pivotal chance to encourage
invite acknowledge and see all around us
the women we had never met before or who
only saw for a few times on campus fifty
years ago but had never kept in touch
with and so that's why the focus was to
have the core women who came in 1969
whether we stayed or not the pivotal
thing was to keep saying what would
bring us together
what would acknowledge what would make
people feel safe protected feel like
they want to tell their stories we
wanted to document it in the way that
might be best for everybody and we know
that some people have come back to
reunions and we're glad of that and that
we all have heard there are people
who've never stepped foot in Yale again
so we we would rather err on the side of
repeating something that maybe some
people saw before or heard before so
that the people who never came back felt
that they had a unifying experience and
that they were understanding and seeing
what has changed at Yale how you made an
impact at Yale
what your legacy is here at you so
having said those things I try to at
least acknowledge to those of you who
may have felt left out why we did what
we did how we came to be here right now
and to welcome you to understanding why
we admire you we respect you but we
won't felt that we needed to have time
to meet with one another so that in some
of the sessions that are really close to
anybody other than the people from 1969
please understand it's that we felt that
there needed to be some times when when
we look to the right when we look to the
left maybe we didn't know those women
then but they were part of the
sisterhood that was here at a critical
time in Yale's history
that is the emphasis of this video
that's why so welcome welcome welcome
and it is my pleasure to salute all of
us by having a toast and asking the
president of Yale to come forward now
most of you have heard his stellar
resume and there's actually a blast of
up here for you Peter most of you have
heard her stellar resume and you know
the long version of all of his accolades
he is a man who has been here who came
for his to make it to do his PhD and he
met his wife at that point in time they
have been here on the University campus
where he is now the Chris our juris
professor of psychology
he has played a role as being not only a
professor but Sheriff's Department and
the Dean of the Graduate School the Dean
of the the College the provost and he
may be the 23rd president of Yale but my
favorite introduction to him is he is
the man who is smart enough confident
enough and lucky enough to be married to
Marta marette peter sala de vera thank
you that was an amazing introduction I
have to say one that I loved and Marta
loved even more I think well look at
yourselves this is an amazing amazing
group I can't tell you how thrilling it
is for Marta and for me to be here with
you and to welcome you back to campus it
is a pleasure it's an honor it's
humbling but it's also fantastic and
thank you thank you for coming back you
know Marta and I have another privilege
which is people thanked us that we were
greeting people as that came in the door
you all and people saying thank you for
putting this on for us and we didn't put
it on
are you I just am lucky enough to work
with a group of people who are willing
to labor hard in putting wonderful
wonderful tributes wonderful events
wonderful commemorations together on
behalf of this University
and the truth is Marta got to say that
that night that Vera was talking about
let's have a celebration and the next
thing you know volunteers and Yale staff
are working together to make it happen
and I just get to say thank you to all
those people who pulled this weekend
together to Eve to Linda and to all the
committee people too many to mention by
name thank you for what you did what
what people are telling me is that
they're having the time of their life
they're delighted to be back and that
makes us all so so grateful so what a
milestone 50 years since co-education
Yale and our panel after dinner with him
more about how that how that happened
but you all changed campus forever you
all that is right give yourself a round
of applause I know you've been doing
that all day but Yale is an immeasurably
better place in 2019 than it was
certainly in 1701 because of what you
did in 1969 and we are thankful for that
we are pleased to welcome so many of you
back to campus and we are especially
gratified to hear about your experiences
whether we're speaking one-on-one or as
part of a panel thank you for sharing
all of that with us so as we commemorate
50 years we salute the classes of 1970
1971 1972 1973
nineteen seventy one two and three I got
a little got a little ahead of myself
there we wish there had been in 1970 but
71 72 and 73 your courage your
determination inspire us and inspire
every member of the Yale community so
let's raise a glass to the Trailblazers
of co-education in the Ale College to
all the remarkable women who have made
Yale what it is today
Cheers it had been my pleasure ten years
ago with my classmate Susan ye C's who
some of you know - on behalf of the
class of 1971 to host a luncheon
celebrating 40 years of co-education we
got pushed back on that but we did it
anyway at the Yale Club in New York and
that brought together it's my
understanding for the first time in
about 20 to 25 years John Wilkinson who
is here and we saw this morning Sam
who's
I admit for the first time ten years ago
unfortunately but also the person what I
say unfortunately it was that was my
media you know I'm pleased that I met
him Ben but it's like what took me so
long it take so long for me to meet him
but now he can't get rid of me what can
I say that's and so he was the one I did
not know but the other person who was at
that luncheon whom I had met because she
interviewed me for Yale and because I
worked for her in this with her in the
summer of 1973 was Elga Wasserman and I
think Diana Wasserman is still in the
room now Danny are you still here you
know and no that was to me was the
pivotal group that no made co-education
happen and it was we heard the stories
about how things happened
and we heard you know but how we were
selected and these are the people who
are just so important to us and as we
were involving John Wilkinson and other
people about you know this particular
weekend and I was that a little bit
chart for us to convince Sam that he
should be talking to us again because
he's talked to us that the cluster
reunion he's talked to different reunion
classes it's like what would make this
different and what he was willing to do
was to do a fireside chat he was willing
and he who specifically would be honored
to be interviewed by Margaret Warner so
you heard the longer introduction for
Margaret this morning you know that she
had worked for PBS for a number of years
you know that she's involved with the
Jackson Institute so I'm gonna get off
the stage to know just introduce the
person who we've really come to hear and
that is the key person with Elga who
made co-education happen for us who was
the assistant working with kingman
brewster who was the secretary of the
university and who has been so involved
with many aspects of yale and he is the
voice of authority about how we came
into being here at Yale and is our
inspiration
so do I make up for that thank you dear
if I believed that so great to be here
though Sam aren't you disappointed
there's not a fire well I'm a yeah I am
disappointed and I but I hope there's
not a fire in the building yeah I do I
agree
well Vera thank you so much and friends
I've been with really remark don't have
well produced this has been I mean I'm
looking at some people and I don't know
how you pulled it off it's really
fantastic so to you
so we're going to talk for I don't know
couple hours but look I'm trying I don't
want to tread the same ground because
everybody was there this morning I
assume and this afternoon but Sam you
were here incredibly to ever for every
event what did we leave out was there
something significant about what
happened and how it happened that you'd
like to highlight that you don't think
was highlighted enough the first thing I
would say is that in in looking at
anything historically I'm not an
historian but all great historians tell
me you look at the context first what
was going on around we had a wonderful
panel this afternoon of people who
talked about Bev gage was the chair and
and talked about the general context in
the United States at this time in the
little book I published about Mayday
1970 I have used the phrase the era of
challenge to Authority and I see this
period as being a period in which we've
come out of the Second World War but we
have a group of aged aged leaders people
who are much older and then all of a
sudden Jack Kennedy was elected
president and and two people my age then
I guess I was 25 27 when Kennedy was
elected it was a whole new world opening
up the young were coming forward were
you going to get new leadership and
everything we did and then of course he
was assassinated and then Martin Luther
King and Bobby Kennedy were assassinate
and these were our heroes depending on
who we were and so on these were the
great heroes then Rachel Carlson comes
out with the Silent Spring
and The Feminine Mystique and the
Stonewall Riots and in Greenwich Village
and the war in Vietnam and all these
challenges were out there and young
people from all over this country were
saying hey wait a minute we don't have
the right leadership they don't know
what they're talking about and we've got
to change and just parenthetically one
of the one of the things came when
Brewster said to me in this period was
you know Sam it's going to be
interesting to see how many of the these
crazy ideas are the gospel 25 years from
now well they all became the gospel I
mean virtually all of them so I like to
remember that nationally this country
was embroiled in a in a revolution in
which young people were saying we are
tired of old leadership and we want
young leadership and we want this
country to change now then let's let's
look at Yale itself Kingman Brewster
became president 1963 when what Rizal
died unhappily of cancer and almost
immediately
Kingman had a wonderful way of being on
vacation whenever something went wrong
yeah and he and I had a deal that one of
us always said because I was his only
assistant and one of us had to be here
so my all my conversations with Kingman
many of these years were on
long-distance telephones to the
Caribbean or someplace like that but the
first protest at Yale was over not a
national issue but the failure of the
philosophy department to grant tenure to
a young man named Richard Bernstein and
none of us had ever even heard of a
protest and yet out in front of
Woodbridge Hall people were camped all
night faculty members were and with
their wives were serving dinner to the
radicals and we were sitting there in
Woodbridge Hall feeling a little bit
like we were under fire
this was a period in which Yale had
terrible labor relations and that was as
much our fault as it was the union's the
administration never understood labor
relations we had terrible financial
problems Yale had a deficit for the
entire 13 years of Brewster's presidency
we the endowment was not big enough we
were trying to do too much kingman was
trying to improve the faculty and pay
more but there was no money to do it in
1964 a Brewster invited three very
distinguished
excuse-me five very distinguished
scientists to come to Yale and examine
the sciences at Yale and the answer was
in a private memo there are only three
scientists at Yale that are worth a damn
imagine that that's how bad the sciences
had become the alumni were up in arms
over a whole series of issues and they
started an organization called luck said
Veritas which was dedicated to getting
Brewster out of office there were the
war issues the civil rights issues and
kingman was desperately trying to
improve the faculty both in the sciences
and other fields so the era in which you
all were admitted there was a whole lot
of things going on outside and those
things were both consuming the minds and
the thoughts of young people but they
were also the things I've just mentioned
at Yale we're consuming our lives so
much as admitting you was the most
exciting thing that we did we had a
whole lot of the work to do you have
opined in other settings that a major I
don't know if you said a great
university but change is real rarely
come in response to internal pressures
but external yet today we heard about
that faculty were unhappy because the
men weren't as accomplished as they'd
like and you know we hear that the male
students the undergrads were also
adjectives
but do you think your paradigm holds yes
I I would still argue that if there had
not been a societal change coming in the
role of women that Yale would never have
gone co-educational at least not at that
time but the pressures of the societal
change were being felt by Princeton and
by Yale and by Dartmouth which were the
only three Ivy League institutions that
had no women involved with them and I
think that the you know there were there
were a couple of students at Lanny Davis
who was chairman on the news in in
1966-67 I think he wrote an editorial
every single day calling us the dumbest
administrators in the entire universe
world because we weren't admitting women
so he had an impact but I do not think
that the someone said today and it may
have been Nancy Malkiel that we were
competitive with Princeton I actually
don't remember being feeling competitive
with Princeton I think we were
competitive with Harvard because they
had Radcliffe and so on I think the
other thing that Vassar the Vassar
project which did not work out had
gotten Yale kind of geared up so I still
think it was more external than than
internal even though so you're saying
you think that the feminist movement was
powerful enough at that early stage to
create a context that kind of yeah let
me tell you a wonderful story there was
one morning when I realized that I had
scheduled an appointment for Kingman to
see
the feminine mystique betty Friedan
betty Friedan I'd never been met Betty
Friedan but I see the only appointment
open was 8 o'clock in the morning it was
clear when Miss Fritton walked in that
she had never been up before 11:30 it
was also clear that she was very unhappy
to be called at 8 o'clock in the morning
to see the president of Yale so she went
in and she went out and that was a day
in which I knew I had to recommend to
the president we didn't have search
committees Peter in those days we just
did things I had to recommend the first
woman master of her college who was
kitty Lessman Catherine Finland Lessman
so a little later in the yeah you're
right great woman a little later in the
morning I went in to see Kingman and I
said I'd like to suggest that you
appoint kitty less - the master of
Davenport College he got up went to the
window and looked out nothing said turn
around he said is she a feminist well
then that's just I we really want to
hear about Kingman Brewster because this
morning I mean I wrote in my notes
mystery man what you were very close to
him I mean we heard john wilkins
wilkinson talk about that he was under
so many pressures money the alums and so
forth but what do you think was really
at the heart of and courage smoked said
there was this committee committee on
co-education and they'd actually prepare
reports about what was missing here
there and hadn't been done and he
wouldn't read them so fill us in on this
character Kingman Brewster was born in
the 1920s he came from a very old New
England family but not people thought he
was very rich he actually was not at all
well-to-do
indeed yeah that was a problem for him
in his entire career but he came from an
old New England family his father was a
NER do well man who constantly was going
to make millions and what never quite
did it his parents were divorced early
his mother Florence Ballentine married a
professor of music at the Harvard Music
School and was an absolutely magnificent
woman way ahead of her time she wasn't a
feminist but she was a feminist in the
old-world sense kingman was a radical
and as an undergraduate he belonged to
the American 1st Firsters movement which
was opposed to the going into the Second
World War and he was he he and Charles
Lindbergh where the two he was the
undergraduate leader in Lindbergh was
the national leader so he was very
radical as an undergraduate he came to
Yale and graduated and then no he came
to he went into the service first no I'm
sorry he graduated and went to into the
service and immediately entered the
service when the country went into war
he just did a total about-face
Mary Louise Brewster born in the same
era went to Vassar but left to marry him
during the wartime and but she was also
a trustee of Vassar afterwards
they both believed the single sex
education was the right way to go and
there was no doubt in their minds that
from an educational point of view this
was the right thing to do what was the
reasoning of that behind that Margaret I
think I'm not sure I ever got to the
bottom of that but I think they they
just believed it but almost in the sense
that we brought been brought up to
believe that having a college education
is about
good thing I think they just believed
that single sex education was right now
Kingman had a little bit of the old blue
you know Stover at Yale the kind of old
blue that this is a man's world and and
and so on so I think that was part of it
but the second thing I want to say about
Kingman is that he was the
quintessential pragmatic and I will
never forget the night after Vassar had
said they didn't want to come we were
Charles Taylor who was the longtime
Provost and he and I were contemporaries
really we both were in college in the
50s and we both wanted to have real
co-education and Charlie and I were
sitting talking to Kingman and the the
drumbeat was going and I think it was
Charlie who turned to Kingman and said
look Kingman there's a snowball up there
and it's coming down the hill and you
have a choice you can get under it and
we'll never see you again or you can
step aside and try to help direct it and
the light went on with Brewster just
like that he said you're telling me we
have to be co-education and we said yes
and he said okay let's do it but he was
he was very pragmatic and he didn't
compromise basic ethical principles but
he knew enough to see when things were
changing that when we decided originally
that all the women were gonna live in
one College it was gonna be Trumbull
College and he went to the meeting John
Wilkinson referred to it he went to a
meeting in Trumbull Kies the only time I
ever worried about Kingman's welfare
physical welfare because they'd build a
stage that was sort of a little tiny
thing like this but it looked like it
was going to collapse anyway and the
students were really angry and he heard
it all he listened to it on as we were
walking out he said you know I think we
just got the message
and so we changed that's a prayer I
think it was a good idea we most of us
or many of us saw this film last night
he saw several but there was a terrific
one and I don't know who produced it I'm
sorry if that person's here I think it
might have been made for the 1989
reunions in any event a much should I
say much younger mr. Chauncey is talking
and you described sorry I couldn't
really take notes but this very to me
strange attitude about the intellectual
capabilities of women that uses worse
prevalent you talked about that little
some man thought women just weren't up
to it to the intellectual jousting tell
us about that
I honestly don't remember that
particular movie so I'm not sure I can
no but I mean just the subject pick up
on that well the there were there were
all kinds of different people at Yale
and I remember a man named George
Pearson that name will mean something to
Judy and some of the rest of you the
great Yale historian George Pearson was
commissioned by first Witt grizzled and
then kingman to create the best history
department in the United States this is
about 1961 and and and George went about
doing it and he had two prejudices no
women in Yale College and no Jewish
people in Yale College so who were his
first two hires John Blum a Jewish man
from MIT and Mary Wright a professor of
Chinese history and I thought men to
myself George has been converted he's
come around he sees the light in one one
of you maybe someone in this room came
to see me in the
first term and said that they had been
in George Pearson's class and that we
that she was one of two women and that
George had announced at the beginning of
this term that there would be it was a
50-minute class and that he would talk
for 35 minutes and then we'd have
discussion and then five minutes would
be assigned for the woman's point of
view so you had this really complex
situation of people who on the one hand
got the message about what was going to
go on and on the other hand they would
they would retreat back they couldn't
get themselves out of the past
and I think maybe that's what I was
talking about in this event because
there were so many different points of
view about why we were taking women and
they ranged from the admissions office
said we can't get any men unless you
admit women the societal pressure
business the there were some people
actually believed that Yale had an
obligation to educate the other 50% of
the population that might be a good idea
but there was no prevailing philosophy
this all happened so fast you've got to
remember that the corporation voted in
November of 68 and Elga and I had to get
everything done by August of the next
year the admission is the facilities
everything and so I I wanna I'm not
proud of this but I want to underscore
the fact there was no great underlying
philosophy and Nancy again talked about
that fact that maybe we'd kind of rushed
into this too quickly and the answer was
we did and you rushed in too quickly and
it was a good idea but yeah I think that
was little
I think the fact that you must not look
for a philosophy in this event it it
didn't exist a lot of people had a lot
of different reasons why women were the
great and will I know you want to come
back to this but the great anchor was
Elga Wasserman because Elga Elga had the
capacity on the one hand to be a damn
good administrator and and to get things
done on the other hand as I said at
Morrie's last night Elga was a pioneer
and she had a vision and and pioneers
who have visions never quite
accomplished everything they want to get
done but she had a vision in which Yale
would have on the faculty in the student
body in the administration 50% men and
50% women at every level in every rank
and and that this that was what true Co
education meant the alga it wasn't just
admitting undergraduate women it was the
whole damn ballgame so if we ever had
any philosophy that we adopted later it
was elgus philosophy and she was the one
who brought that to us it didn't work we
we did not we haven't yet quite
succeeded in achieving elgus goal but i
think that that's the way it turned out
and did she how does she feel about
being sidelined that means it sounds
like the president Brewster does it
didn't I mean on the one hand he
depended on her she was doing half the
job you were but it's business about not
not giving her a real position she was
an assistant what was that about well
let me tell you two things
I'll give you an analogy because I think
some of you may understand it better and
then I'll bring it back to Elgar a lot
of you have heard of Bill coffin the
great
chaplain of the time
and bill was a bill was himself a
revolutionary in the best sense of the
word and passionate in this belief about
civil rights and the draft and they have
anti-vietnam war kingman and bill coffin
fought like tigers day after day after
day but you could never have found two
better friends they fought all the time
because bill was the idealist kingman
had to make the damn place run and so
they were clashing with each other every
day of the week and yet they loved each
other now I won't say that Elgon and
kingman loved each other but they deeply
respected each other and yet i mean i
think that's as it turns out i think
it's very healthy for in university
because anyone who's president i mean
this man knows better than anybody in
the world his president it constantly
visionaries and and missionaries are
coming and saying you help me get make
my thing work and how many dozens come
into a president of university every
year i don't know but there's a whole
lot of them and they want money and they
want help and they want everything the
president favors certain ones of those
because he or she thinks it's a good
idea and kingman ultimately believe the
co education was a good idea but Elga
never as bill never did Elgon never
stopped believing in her principle and
heard her goal of for this institution
and and kingman never stopped trying to
make it work and so the conflict which
is is perhaps overplayed as a as as an
angry or i don't think that ever existed
now as to her title that was a very
separate issue alga wanted to be the
associate dean or the
Dean of Yale College the Dean of your
college did not want to be told by the
president who was going to be his
deputies or his assistants and who was
the Dean George May professor French
wonderful man but he would not accede to
being told from Woodbridge Hall who was
going to be in his office he felt that
was his prerogative and that he was
going to appoint the people and it may
have been a mistake for us to go to
George and ask him to make this
appointment because maybe if he had
thought it up it might have happened so
I I think that's a separate issue which
gets into the politics of how
universities operate so it was not
anything deeper that can only didn't
want someone so strong I I happen to
have actually felt and I talked to Ella
about this I happen to actually thought
she had more power as an assistant to
the president than she would have had as
a an associate dean of Yale College I
just thought in the scheme of things it
might have been a better but her view
and I it was based in her feeling about
the academic side in many ways that
being an associate dean was a more
important academic position as opposed
to being an administrator so I know
other people I asked this this morning
and it got a laugh but I I'd really like
to know how did it happen that even the
most basic like having bathrooms in the
classroom buildings was overlooked
I have to tell you a story first stories
are great
there was a Registrar vo college his
name was Ronald C Marsh he graduated in
the class of 1917 and he was registrar
from 1917 until God knows when he he was
in the in the Strathcona and he had
thirteen ladies who worked for him and
they all sat there with pencils
recording grades
Ronald always wore the same attire not I
mean he changed got it cleaned and stuff
he always wore a very heavy gray suit
this is in the era of no co-education of
no air conditioning he wore a stiff
detachable white collar and a Yale blue
type one of the thirteen ladies who
worked in his office was mrs. Marsh we
were not allowed to call her Vesta she
was to be called mrs. Marsh Ronald had
on his desk a telephone and a key and
each day if a lady wished to make a
telephone call she had to stand right
next to Ronald and make the telephone
call and if she wanted to go to the
ladies room there was one and SSS then
on the 8th floor she had to take the key
from Ronald and Ronald only allowed them
to go once in the morning and once in
the afternoon
now bathrooms were a problem for
generations we did we worried first
about these sorts of things in the
places where the women were gonna live
and make sure that those were all
working and there was a famous story
about my wanting to take the bath the
showers out of Vanderbilt and put
bathtub because my five sisters had said
women wanted bathtubs and then the women
said no you leave them in there but it
there were so many buildings at Yale
that we just in the seven months that we
had
to do everything else we did not have
time we did somebody went around and
looked in every place but we just didn't
get it done it was - we had too little
time to get it done remember one nice
person who was here saw me earlier
reminded me that she lives in New York
and she said you know to have all the
permits to renovate your apart your
kitchen in New York City takes longer
then then we had in order to get all
this done for all the women it's it's
we're guilty but all of us have done
renovations can sympathize affect but I
want to get to questions from the
audience but sitting back and reflecting
now one how momentous do you think it
was co-education and in the sort of
roster of really urgent emergencies that
you had to deal with where does this
rank at please don't flatter us but
where does that having women here rank
in in in what you've achieved and the
greatest legacy well I'll start one step
higher many of you may know professor
Jay Gitlin in the history department
who's who's really our sort of
university historian he's not officially
that but he knows a lot about Yale
history and he teaches a class that
relates to Yale history which I attend
and he and I have a big argument about
when did the Old Yale become the new
Yale and my argument is that the period
of of the challenge to Authority in the
period of your coming to Yale is the
period in which the Old Yale becomes the
new Yale because it involves women
minority students it involves the period
in which the Yale faculty recognizes
that there are really good phd's other
than Yale PhDs and we begin having men
and later women come from the great
State University
where they've always taught women and so
I think this era and I won't pick a
particular part of it just but to say
this is the this is the time that the
old Yale became the new Yale as to the
sort of relative maybe difficulty or so
on
we worked much further ahead in planning
for the admission of minority students
that is Arthur Howe had actually started
a program and in 1956-57 called the ABC
program and we began planning and so by
the time a larger group of black
students came we had already developed
the afro-american studies department
we'd already developed the company after
American Cultural Center and so I think
that was the one that we probably did
the best job on I'm not saying it was a
perfect job but I think we did the best
job and we had magnificent students who
came in that first tranche of people I
would rank the core education thing is
the second most difficult because we
only had 7 months but there's no doubt
that having only 6 weeks to prepare for
May Day was the most difficult of the
things I was involved with but I will
also say that this guy learned more from
those 3 events than he ever learned in
the rest of his life I mean I learned so
many different things about people about
human nature I learned about minority
events that that never would have
occurred to me if it hadn't been for
those students beating on our door
pushing us hard for financial aid and
those kinds of things and the same with
all of you I learned an enormous amount
I mean I think those kinds of
experiences are what really make your
life and they were early in my life so I
was lucky so can you give us one example
that is emblematic for that
yeah is Shirley Daniels here where's
Shirley Daniels Shirley and another
minority student Euclid Irving were
assigned by the Black Student
Association to deal with me and I don't
know Shirley how many times I recall we
met Friday at I don't know 11 o'clock
every morning something like that and
you know I kind of thought you know you
know students they won't show up after
the first couple of meeting well Shirley
and Euclid were there every single
Friday and every single Friday they
pushed me about the financial we were
talking primarily about financial aid I
learned things that I never would have
learned I came from a family that didn't
have a lot of money I was a scholarship
student at Yale but I was very lucky I
came from a family that had but I didn't
understand the fact that for example
that if a minority student came here it
was not only needing the financial aid
but it was the loss of his or her income
to the family income that was
devastating for the family well now this
is the kind of thing I I wouldn't have
ever learned if it hadn't been for
Shirley and Euclid coming after me and
and I think that was incredibly
important in my education to just see
issues that I didn't ever encounter in
my own life let's open this is
fascinating Sam I could continue for
quite a while
but I know people here would like to ask
some questions are you gonna sort of
filter them in case they're angry cause
you sound as if you were incredibly
adept at hanging sort of thing so I know
I ignored the right side of the room
today so I want to take questions from
wherever they come but yes the lady in
the red jacket it are their micro there
any microphones class of 73 we've heard
a lot of talk about Yale and Princeton
and Harvard and the Ivy League and I
have a very good friend who went to the
University of Virginia the next year the
first co educated class which was
virtually done under court order and
they didn't even bother taking out the
urinals because they didn't want no one
wanted the women there I'm curious
whether Yale paid you know where it was
the Ivy League oblivious to and I have
another friend who went the University
of North Carolina and the first freshman
class that admitted women in 1965 I'm
curious if if Yale was following the
trends among other previously all-male
schools or was it totally focused on the
Ivy League and aware of not just the
trend of co-educational schools and
faculty who had taught at state
universities but other schools around
the country that we're starting to go
co-ed I'm a little you know I'm ashamed
of this answer and I was ashamed this
this morning I guess it was when the
panel that had Nancy Malkiel and company
on it some of whom were a little
critical in our planning we did not
really know we were going to be
co-educational until
member of 1968 the trustees on the whole
were we thought were favorable but there
were two or three who felt so strongly
against it we weren't sure how the board
would actually vote and from that moment
on it was like being in a in a
long-distance race you know you just had
to start running so we did not do any
studies or anything the only thing we
did that was really smart and I'm I am
unable to remember her name someone may
here remember there was a wonderful
woman who was had been president Barnard
and president of became vice chancellor
of UCLA and up maybe I her name will
come to me but we did ask her to come
and talk to us about co-education and
some of the some of the ideas and and
she was wonderful and brilliant but we
didn't do studies or anything like that
we just got our head down and figured
out how we were gonna get five hundred
women into the place where we gonna
house them how we're gonna make them
safe as we could and and those issues so
I'm embarrassed to answer this question
that way but no we did not
I'll go here and here you go right
behind
some michaelis whoo
Oh I'm Caroline Patel I'm from Jonathan
Edwards college class of 71 so I have a
scrapbook and there are actually two
letters from Yale in that scrapbook
there's one that's in March saying you
now have we're now asking you to send
additional materials and then there was
the dated something like April 19th the
the actual acceptance letter and so I
was wondering if you could explain a
little bit about the process that went
on and also did you were you overwhelmed
by the number of applications were they
more than you expected less than you
expected well as to expected we had no
idea how many applicants would be but
remember that the decision was made in
descent in November of 1968 the
admission of men for that year had
already begun and and so the admissions
office the undergraduate admissions
office was already underway admitting a
class of men so that we made the
decision elegant I made the decision
that we would let them do the paperwork
they'd had to assemble all the documents
sent out the printed materials and so on
but that she and I would do the whole
admissions process ourselves so I'm not
sure but I think we got 11,000
applicants um but I'm not a hundred
percent sure of that figure but I think
that's what it was so we knew that we
couldn't get our work done as fast as
the male team was getting the admission
of men was getting done so I think we
sent out materials instead of what you
would do in a normal admissions process
if we saw something was missing we
immediately wrote to that person and
said we didn't get your teachers report
or we didn't get this we didn't get that
so it was a little bit of sort of
rolling along and we'd make a decision
that this person was going to get in
then we put that file aside I have a
vivid memory of the March
night it was miserable night and I
walked back to my home with one of those
great big file boxes with nothing but
admissions folders and I don't know how
many hundred were in it and I knew I had
to read them all before the next morning
and I looked down the file and they all
looked exactly the same that way you
could see the pink form and the blue
form and the white form but then there
was one in the middle it was very thick
and I said to myself that's that's the
only one that's gonna be interesting and
so I put it at the very end because I
knew I had to stay awake and that one
would keep me awake so it was a process
now in the one of the panels they talked
about the things that Ella and I were
thinking about as we admitted women and
and the famous remark I made that if you
had four brothers you got in well it was
absolutely true and there was one woman
the other night who came and there you
are back there she had four brothers if
you had three brothers you were likely
to get in and if you had two we
certainly looked hard the second thing
we looked for was women who had
experiences that would toughen them up
and that might have been being a a
violinist who had achieved some kind of
national stature it might have been an
athlete who had achieved some some kind
of stature
there was another woman who I talked
with today who had lived for the
previous two years before applying in
other countries so we of course had a
kind of academic cutoff but we were
mostly looking for people because we
knew that this was going to be a very
difficult place for a lot of women to
come to and I think we avoided and I
hope there we didn't avoid them all but
I think we avoided a woman who was an
only child
okay apparent well you did okay maybe we
didn't know but any right we were we
were reluctant to admit someone who we
thought might find the hostility of the
masculine campus something that they
couldn't deal with so can i yeah my name
is Chris Citroen class of 71 I'd like to
ask you about probably everyone's most
heated choke point was Yale's
obligation to the nation to produce
1,000 future male leaders of America and
many of us if you asked this would be
the number one thing we was a
controversy and I would like to know
what your conversations with him about
that were yeah to be sure everyone knows
the context Kingman had said and I don't
remember exactly when he first said it
though we were obligated to educate a
thousand male leaders never has a
greater mistake ever been made by a yale
president than saying that and and i
guess we i guess we sort of know it
pretty quickly on it came in part from
our fear of what the alumni reaction
would be to the admission of women
because we didn't have any talk about
not making studies we hadn't sort of
pulled the alumni or done anything to
find out how it their feel we had the
sense that the alumni would be very
opposed to co education that was wrong
yes John Wilkinson said this morning the
minute a male alumnus woke up and
realized he had a daughter he all of a
sudden thought this was a good idea but
having said that Brewster had the
problem of how to back off of it
this was combined with our the way we
were going to deal with it was we were
going to build two new residential
colleges on the corner of Grove
and Whitney and we had the money and we
had the plans drawn and we had the
building long everything torn down in
the corner and then the course the city
of New Haven wouldn't give us the permit
to to build them so that pulled that the
rug out from under there I I think I
think Kingman knew he had made a mistake
but I think he felt having made the
public statement that he had to sort of
back it up but he gently he gently
backed off and I can't actually remember
the exact numbers as the years go on but
I think he was willing to to to back off
of that but he didn't want to have to
make a public statement about it
everybody told no I mean I don't want to
that's too easy to say when he said it I
knew why he was saying it I knew we had
come out of a meeting in New York with
the lux ad Veritas group that were out
for his scalp and they told us if we
admitted women they were going to come
after us
and so we III I would actually have to
say I went along with him when he made
it but it was a terrible mistake you
said something in an interview following
up on that in the Yale alumni magazine
new one on the on the stance or whatever
that something about speaking of context
that Kingman also was looking at fellow
Ivy leaders who were losing their job
yes okay explain that a little um in
this period and I can't give you all the
exact dates Nate Posey at Harvard Grace
and Kirk at Columbia gala at Hearn will
at Penn and one other all lost their
jobs because radical movements had
resulted in terrible injury fires people
died and it was felt that these
individuals were not up to the times and
so on
and and Kingman was constantly trying to
wind his way between the two nancy
Malkiel mentioned something today which
is I think we're talking about and that
was she mentioned that Kingman had made
a comment about the his belief that a
black person could not get a fair trial
in the United States and the second one
was his anti Vietnam war declaration one
of the things that Kingdom and I talked
about and Charlie Taylor enormous amount
was what is right for a college a
university president to talk about
that's of a public of a national stature
as opposed to a local university thing
and so on the the the fair trial of
black person getting a fair trial we
were going into the made a business a
judge the judge in the Bobby Seale trial
in preliminary hearings had seen two
black men in the back of the room
reading a newspaper and he had found
them in contempt of court and put him in
jail and this just went like a spark and
the students at Yale were enraged and
the the black community in New Haven was
enraged and Kingman as a lawyer was
enraged to have seen a judge do that so
we spent 48 hours writing that sentence
and then he put it in they talked to the
ill college faculty and allowed the Yale
News to attend the faculty meeting he
wanted that statement out in the Vietnam
War him he eventually made a very strong
statement against the Vietnam War a lot
of people don't know that one of
Kingman's very closest friends was
McGeorge Bundy who at that time was the
national security adviser to Lyndon
Johnson Mac Bundy was one of the
architects of the Vietnam War I remember
two occasions with Kingman and Mac one
in the Caribbean and one
no Haven in which the shouting match was
really something as they fought over the
issue and I remember I said to Mac you
should get out of that damn place and he
looked at me and he said you're on
America this was really bitter stuff
between people who were all friends I
mean we all liked each other but
Kingman's belief was that if the
national issue affected the student body
or the faculty he had an obligation to
speak out on it and that was the place
he drew the place he drew the line which
I think I won't ask Peter to comment but
presidents I mean Rick Levin dealt with
that and then you know it's are you an
intellectual leader in this country but
you know where where do you go where
where is the line now there's someone
over here in navy blue who's been dying
to speak go ahead oh no it you need a
microphone this is very trivial and it
goes back three questions what was the
role of what was the role of Enki Clark
in admitting women when Arthur how
resigned as Dean of Admissions and
Arthur how is an under-recognized man in
Yale history he was the one who really
believed in the admission of minority
students and started the talk and he was
the one who who suggested to the New
York Times that women ought to be
admitted in 1956 and what grizzled had
that wonderful called him in and said
Arthur I agree with you about admitting
women but don't you every day or say it
again in public yeah he resigned in 1963
to go to head the American field service
and Kingman decided that that staff that
was there was too old and not a modern
group of admissions people and so he
chose inky Clark to headed up Clark was
carrying out what Arthur Howard started
in many ways inky Clark was great he
hired a magnificent young group of
people to come in and do this thing he
did what he was asked to do which was to
change the face of Yale his great
weakness was that he had no sense of
diplomacy and he was abrupt and and
straightforward what he said was right
but he kind of said it in a way that
didn't it was a little bit angry and but
he was he was very good because he
brought the institution from an
old-fashioned way of looking at things
to a modern way and I think inky felt
he'd done his job he didn't stay too
long I can't remember the number years
maybe six years of the most and and then
he became headmaster of a school
somewhere but he was a great guy and he
was good at it but boy he didn't he
never went to diplomatic school no and
with the alums yes congresswoman
presidents matter and I wanted to say
Sam that Kingman Brewster mattered Thank
You Martha very much and to Martha and
to Peter it's not disrespectful but the
tone that you've set in 2019 makes a
difference I just want to take this
brief moment to go back appointed to on
the question of the african-american
students surely in Euclid and the
diligence in which the cultural groups
made a difference and I can oppose the
push in that context and the reception
earlier we were introduced to the
cultural houses miraculously under your
leadership in terms of that era there 50
years old - no one would ever even
imagine that their fifty years old the
Women's Studies program I think that was
enormous ly innovative to have those
programs at that time even though we
were reaching for diversity so let me
just focus on the afroamerican house as
you well know that was not done without
pain you made the point that there were
brilliant men initially that came
scholars themselves that pushed the
university for the vitality and the
importance of understanding
african-american history I love Yale for
the fact that I think history was really
a theme that ran through our studies dr.
Lewis Gates is a product of Yale
University we should never have to be a
man forgive me but he was very
respectful of women students at the time
but the point is is that we should never
shy away from being more superior than
Princeton on this experiment anybody
went to grad school that's okay we
should never shy away for what we went
through and I'll just throw a personal
anecdote then I will just pose a
question so I move quickly as possible
there was a question earlier today
how you compared 1969 in terms of change
to now 20 19 so forgive me my my
classmates this happens to also be the
year of return this is 400 years for
enslaved Africans who arrived in New
England in 1619 what an interesting time
to come and do all these historical
things at that time but we became the
mother of African American Studies
programs across America this is we're
not celebrating that now but I'm just
trying to put together all the historic
I think moments and that we were going
through if everybody if I'm correct and
just this year I took up something that
people would initially respond to as
well as a member of Congress engaged in
this kind of debate and that is of
course the HR 40 is the Commission to
study reparations proposals and my goal
was to reflect on where I came from but
also Yale's pioneering spirit about
history and so I view this commission as
an attempt it hasn't been passed yet but
it's going further than it's ever gone
leadership of the House and members of
Congress from all over the nation
co-sponsoring it but the point is is
that it's about racial reconciliation
and then ultimately what do you do in
that period of history my question for
you as you lay the groundwork for many
of these folk the Blasingame if you
remember you can't like you brought him
here he was considered a genius in terms
of building that department's boom that
surely highlighted what do you view
mixing women with that how do you view
that there's a significant part of the
leadership this whole cultural
revolution of acknowledging Asians
Hispanics Latinos African Americans
women all groups
that'd heretofore been left out and we
and seemingly in that period of time or
acknowledging all of them hope I left
everybody got everybody in the Women's
Studies Program
did you all talk about that significance
that the corporation board did they were
they impressed do they know what you did
and I sit down on this note do they know
that you kept New Haven from exploding
in May of 79 when Kingman shut down the
University and said everybody go out of
class I remember when when they and I
know there was some in 69 it was it was
70 made a 70 the spring of 70 when they
let us out as they say cuz I remember in
July you know sort of digging myself in
to get those papers in that we didn't
get in at that time but I mean all of
that was with women here and I and I
want to say to the women who are here
you were part of keeping that the lid on
you really were I think you work I mean
you there most of you were involved in
this and you kept the lid on while we
were really in one of the most explosive
historical moments not hysterical
moments of history and we had all these
different groups because the
african-american students were holed up
at a at a at one of the secret societies
somebody else was somewhere else
other people were hanging out in Commons
we all had our spaces but we all seem to
know that the administration respected
our dignity and we're going to stand
with us on that dignity otherwise this
place could have I won't finish the
sentence but I yield back as they say on
the floor of them I feel they know the
significance of it that gets this hot
mustard
let me try and answer a couple of
questions that are so embedded there
first of all the Yale trustees the you
know Corporation at that time was
incredibly supportive some of you will
remember the the meetings in the rink
7,000 people in the rink to argue over
our
you see or whatever it was we were
arguing over and when we had one of
those meetings we called the members of
the corporation and I would say of the
16 members aside from the president 14
were there for every event and sat in
the rink and participated they didn't
speak I don't think but they part they
were there so they were they were very
supportive we also had three four great
afro-american trustees at the time three
were women Marian Wright Edelman eleanor
holmes norton and barbara price co and
then judged leon Higginbottom of the
federal court was also and those people
gave us guidance and understanding that
we might never otherwise have had
secondly about the cultural houses some
we I don't remember how we learned it
but we we knew that if you would no
matter how many initial black let's say
black students we admitted they had to
have a place of sense of safety and and
getting together and so on and so the
idea of the cultural house seemed to us
to be almost the number one thing that
ought to be done with regard to the
afro-american studies major the great
heroes of this were a black student
named Robby Robinson and Charles Taylor
the Provost and Charlie who was Provost
and therefore he had a lot of things to
do
undertook to personally develop with
Robby the who was a senior and there
were other students on the committee
I've forgotten all their names but to
undertake the development of that major
with the faculty and
I think everybody understood that in
addition to needing a place where a
small group of people could feel
comfortable you needed an intellectual
place in which they could also feel
comfortable and so the development of
the afro-american studies major was to
us of the highest priority fascinating
questions yes lady in the blue um we've
been talking a lot about the arrival of
women in 1969 I'm sure thank you sorry
Judith Vicki owned in 1973 and Berkeley
College we've been talking a lot about
the arrival of women at Yale and I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about the first years of women on campus
as part of the of Yale College and
particularly the belief that I had
always had but maybe it's not true maybe
it's imaginary that we were called the
experiment in Co education for the
entire time that I was here is an here
and Perkins and I guess she's not here
if you have not read Anne's book you you
absolutely must read it she has written
a PhD dissertation which is transformed
into a very good history book which
documents the first two years of
co-education at Yale and I can't make it
any better I will say about it a couple
of things one is that I think without
Elga we would have we would have had a
really tough time because I think she
was our spiritual leader as well as our
administrative leader and I think she
was the one who kept the fires burning
in in those first two years and kept the
fire underneath our behinds which which
was important
what was the second part all the
experiment yeah I don't know where that
came from the it was not and we were not
going to back off so there was never an
intention that this would we try it out
and see if it worked and then deciding
that I I don't know where that came from
except I think it may have come as a as
from someone who was unhappy that we
weren't admitting more women and
therefore use this is a kind of
derogatory comment but there was never
any intention to backing off and going
back at all someone raising their hand
way back there yes I'm curious bless
Williams Brown Davenport 71 I'm curious
whether the administration ever did
anything to prepare the men for our
arrival great question
I'm gonna I'm gonna take the liberty of
before I answer your question somebody
today in the afternoon seminar said
something that I have think is
incredibly important we need to teach
men about themselves
we need a mandatory course for Yale
males because the masculinity of Yale is
not yet gone it's still very much a part
of the institution now over to your
question absolutely nothing and I mean
it nothing was done I'm not sure but
what the the word groups of men who were
who wanted to be hospitable and they I
think in individual colleges and
individual groups there were things that
happened where men tried to be welcoming
and friendly and stuff like that there
there is some disagreement say between
John Wilkinson myself I think there were
more undergraduate men who are against
co-education that he he does I think
there were a fair number I would think
maybe 50% of the
who it wasn't they didn't like women or
something it was just that they thought
Yale should be male so I but we didn't
do anything to educate the men right
there let's let's get the microphone
right behind way speaking at Glenn
Murphy
Calvin 71 speaking as a male who was at
Yale during both before and after the
co-education I would remind you that
co-ed week oh yeah was instigated by the
male undergrad obviously collation avi
SOI fur and we managed to accommodate
750 women without the world spinning off
its axis so I think it's fair to say
that the male undergraduate population
not in its entirety but was out ahead of
you as far as Co education was concerned
and didn't need any institutional
preparation to make it happen let me let
me I'm gonna I'm gonna pick a fight with
you okay I don't think that's what the
questioner was talking about you're
absolutely right avi SOI fer did a
fabulous job of putting together co
education week and I four or five
hundred women came to Yale and spent the
week when two classes lived in the dorms
and everything but I think the question
is a different question and that is that
this institution since 1701 until 1969
was all-male and it developed an
atmosphere and an ethos which is
embedded in every wall and every ceiling
and every floor of the institution
everyone says and I'm a fan of Morris -
Dave Aaron says maureesa so they've take
women in they have all these nice
parties and so on you just go into the
his floor and find me a woman a picture
of a woman yeah there's no picture of
any woman on the first floor there on
the stairway there up a stairs they're
hidden now I don't want to I don't want
to pick on Morrie's but I I firmly I
firmly believe because I got so
passionate about omitting women to Yale
I have spent my time thinking about this
subject I have five or six undergraduate
advisees every year I've got about 20 in
college now half um roughly or women
they tell me that they feel that Yale is
still a masculine institution and now
they're not scared they're not afraid
they're not they're they're going about
their business but I think men have to
learn about masculinity here we have
women's studies we don't have men we
don't have men's studies you laugh but
listen men are not so good at at
understanding when they get together as
a group how at a place like Yale how
offensive they can be so I you know I
know what you're talking about and I I
agree that that that coed week was a
great thing but I think if I hate them
tell the president what to think about
it I I do believe that if we want to be
really co-educational one of the things
we have to do is to teach men to
understand what being masculine is and
how it affects the other sex in that am
I getting the signal I think yes right
here hi I'm June don't get mad at me
Branford class of 1972
I like many of you I'm sure I have been
an alumni schools volunteer interviewer
for many years and I've been told by
high school students applying that Yale
is well known now as the gay friendly
Ivy when people were talking about the
cultural houses it brought
memories when I was here as a student
and volunteered for Dwight Hall and
there was a homosexuality discussion
group that gradually changed its name
openly to gaze at Yale when we talk
about bringing women to a men's school I
remember there was some discussion about
this was a good thing because it would
make sure that there were heterosexual
manly men at Yale and having close
friends who were gay men at the time
although I didn't have a close woman
friend who identified as as gay or
lesbian I'm sure there are it was still
sort of not a manly thing to do the
other thing is that I want an award as a
junior and the count for the qualities
that the award was named for and one of
them was manliness and I used I used
this a lot in law school applications of
Lincoln hey you know I not only was a
good student but I was manly it's always
raised this question for me it was you
know Yale is the mother of men and you
know you'd swim naked in the pool and
you'd don't know lunch with the other
guys at Morrie's and there was a
reinforcement of a particular kind of
masculinity but it was a masculinity
that presumably was quite fearful of
being perceived as feminine in any way
so I'm wondering now at what point the
the change in Yale became such that it
is perceived as a friendly IV for gay
lesbian queer binary transgender the
whole new area of gender you know back
when we were going to Yale it was all
you're a man or a woman but now there's
gender and gender identity and if we're
talking about how you identify yourself
as a person you know masculine still
masculine environment like this I think
that'd be a really interesting area to
discuss and to explore going back in
time to 1969
did this come up in discussion that we
wanted the kind of men we wanted Yale to
admit were
only heterosexual men and we would bring
in women to make that possible or did
nobody even talk about him know that in
1969 that subject wouldn't have come up
because those kinds of subjects didn't
come up ever in nineteen but I will say
this and I'm not I'm retired I'm not an
administrator now but I will say this
based on my advisees and other students
I know III marvel at how different the
world is today and the view of
undergraduates today about sexual issues
it is it's a totally different world
than the world I was brought up and then
maybe maybe some of you I don't I don't
know a lot older than you are but
there's no question that these all these
issues I don't know where they gales
more gay-friendly or any other friendly
than any other institution I just don't
know whether there are statistics that
would bear that out or not but I do know
that the issue of sexual identity or
sexual orientation or something like
that is really a kind of not high on
people's agenda in in meeting each other
I mean they may be they may be
interested in the subject of sexual
identity and want to talk about it in a
class or in a discussion group but if
but there are students at Yale who are
friends of students who are who have
other sexual identity than they do and
they just all get along fine so to me
that's an issue that us old-timers have
to learn to deal with this will be the
last question and it's the lady also in
blue gray yes you
hi I'm Janet Weiss class of 73 earlier
you said you had a disagreement with Jay
Gitlin about when the LDL became the new
yell and you gave us your answer I am
curious about what his answer was
is I wish Jay were here and could defend
himself I I think Jay is undecided I
think he thinks I'm wrong but I don't
think he knows where he actually thinks
the old Yale became the new Yale and I'm
not sure actually whether he thinks it
has become the new Yale so I he maybe as
an historian he may see this more in a
kind of gradual level of moving forward
whereas I see the this particular error
as very abrupt very different very
changing but I I'm reluctant to give you
a particular time he also was interested
in the period of when Yale moved from
being a Seminary if you will that is
training people to go into the ministry
and and it had its first non clerical
president or rector so I but I don't
think he ever has given me a specific
date or time then he went along with so
I I feel badly I can't answer it but I
really can't so please join me in
thanking Sam country that was fabulous
but being really fabulous
[Applause]